[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois le philosophe
alain badiou qui publie un livre
sobrement intitulé trempe aux presses
universitaires de france
donald trump a proposé aujourd'hui avec
benyamin nétanyahou un plan de paix
censé mettre fin au conflit
israélo-palestinien est ce que celui ci
vous a surpris
très pas une politique pro israélienne
considérables efforts tu es constamment
réaffirmé depuis le début mais là
effectivement c'est tout de même
singulier d'aller jusqu'à ce point où on
reconnaît quand même pratiquement
contrairement à des décisions
internationales impérative antérieures
reconnaît pratiquement les annexions
pratiqué par l'état d'israël sur le dos
des palestiniens et peut semble qu'il ya
là un caractéristiques de trump aussi
c'est à dire prendre des décisions
surprenantes un peu un peu raide un peu
qu'ils qui expose tout de même aussi la
paix du monde des nouveaux avatars et
quitte même quelquefois tamponné un peu
ça peu après de revenir dessus ou pas
etc
donc je suis pas vraiment surpris pas
vraiment surpris doit il faut pas se
laisser surprendre par trump c'est une
règle essentielle
on peut aussi estimer que c'est un pur
étalage d'une cure manifestation de
force un étalage de la force aussi aussi
bien de la part des états unis que
d'israël ils sont aux positions de force
ils ont l'air de dire au fond c'est ça
ou rien et puis toute façon vous
refuserez et c'est pas grave parce que
oui bon on s'en fout des palestiniens
aujourd'hui rue bien sûr bien sûr c'est
çà çà çà entérine largement une
situation on ne te voilà de fait qui est
qu est constitué et au fonctionne même
façon que les français ou les gros ou la
grande-bretagne autrefois quand il était
en situation de force ou du fesc
conduira à peu près la même manière oui
sauf que la relation entre trimpe israël
n'est pas exactement une relation de
type colonial c'est quand même un peu
nouveau c'est à dire dans le cas
du colonialisme pur et dur on avait une
possession territoriale qu on
revendiquait ce qui s'y passait on en
est comptable après tout puisque c'était
tandis que la trup il dit à une
puissance étrangère extérieure malgré
tout qui n'est pas n'était pas partie de
son empire à proprement parler il dit
fait que vous voulez voilà vous aurez ma
bénédiction
c'est un tout petit peu différente oui
je pensais pas spécialement au rapport
que la france ou la grande-bretagne 30
ce n'est avec les pays qu'ils avaient
eux-mêmes colonisés mais simplement
qu'on pouvait entretenir avec des
puissances de moindre importance qui au
fond ne pouvait qu'accepter nous diktat
oui mais là c'est pas un diktat c'est
une c'est un encouragement ce vis-à-vis
d'israël mais stagnent les amis des
palestiniens à la bombe et les
palestiniens c'est même pas une nation
constituée alors finalement en un
certain sens beaucoup de monde les
considère comme rien d'un mail montrant
de même donald tram sera le premier
président des états unis et participer
vendredi à la grand messe des pro life
comme ça qu'on appelle aux états unis
les les partisans vallée plutôt les
adversaires de l'apport de l'avortement
alors même qu'il avait dit qu'il était
lui pro-choice donc favorable à
l'avortement
là aussi est ce qu'il vous surprend je
crois que trump quelqu'un qui cherchent
eux aussi
quels sont les clientèles diverses et
variées qu'il peut tenter de rallier à
un moment ou à un autre dans un calcul
qui finalement est aussi un calcul
électoral qu aucun président ne perd de
vue là ce n'est pas une caractéristique
de 32 souhaitait être réélu et là je
pense qu'il s'est dit que dans la
situation des équilibres actuels
internes aux états unis manifesté y
compris avec cette espèce de
détermination un peu un peu arrogante
qui est la sienne pour les anti
avortement
ça serait utile je pense qu'un calcul
d'utilité purement et simplement les
calculs d'utilité dans la composition
toujours compliqué aux états unis des
différents groupements région profession
et c'est qu'il faut savoir coalisés un
moment donné pour être élu et donc ça
veut dire que le fait qu'ils soient pour
ou contre l'avortement n'entre
absolument pas en ligne de compte
n'aurait pas du tout sûr que ça entre
réellement lignes de court d'ailleurs
les questions de savoir pourquoi être un
peu contre quoi il est c'est un travail
fin 1 1 c'est un travail fin et il faut
être à l'affût de twitter tous les
matins pour le pour le savoir vraiment
je pense que et il a un côté de ce point
de vue là qui soumet la question de
l'exercice du pouvoir de façon
extrêmement fortes dans sa vision
personnelle et à ses intérêts personnels
et en ce sens
ça le rend si on est strictement dans le
domaine de la rationalité politique un
tout petit peu imprévisible quand même
alors dans votre livre alain badiou
sobrement intitulé trempe vous parler à
son égard de fascisme démocratique
il n'est pas le seul pour vous vous y
mettez également berlusconi qui serait
en fait comme souvent l'arrêté les
italiens d'ailleurs une sorte de
laboratoire au niveau politique
qu'ensuite les autres il en hérite
il le transforme le fascisme mais on
parlera peut-être aussi du mouvement sac
étoilé de salvini
donc il ya eu bel homme du sco dit il ya
eu 10 colas sarkozy qui vous aviez
consacré un livre célèbre qui vous a
d'ailleurs rendu célèbre de quoi sarkozy
est il le nom un titre qui a été
beaucoup plagié depuis lors donc il y
aurait berlusconi il y aurait sarkozy
aurait train qui en aurait d'autres
aussi mais ce serait les trois qui
représentait ce que vous appelez le
fascisme démocratique
oui alors je voudrais durant c'est la
chose parce que d'une certaine manière
entre sarkozy berlusconi d'un côté trême
de l'autre il ya quand même une
différence je pense il ya une différence
parce que les deux premiers me
paraissent plutôt être l'apparition sur
la scène d'un d'un style délibérément
que j'avais appelé délibérément un style
voyou
voilà c'est une statistique plutôt
qu'une détermination véritable est une
manière de se présenter deux par les
bulgares on vous parlait de faire des
déclarations et c'est un peu à
l'emporte-pièce comme ça d'affiché quand
même un certain anti intellectualisme
commerciale si je puis dire c'est
toujours quand sarkozy avait dit c'est
absolument absurde d'apprendre à des
gens qui vont être postiers à lire la
littérature classique des choses comme
ça et c'était la forme mineure de la
chose avec trump ou bold barreaux ou
même maudit en had ou dutartre aux
philippines on a tout de même car on a
un grand bond en avant au dessus 1 en un
cran de son tu as la foi dans la
violence du traité de façon dans
certains cas extrêmes or nahd mais
latente aux états unis est présente tout
de même et aussi auront à ce que je
crois exki batterie a parlé de fascisme
une stylistique continue qui consiste à
considérer que la légitimation d'un
pouvoir se fait non pas dans des codes
partagés mais dans la singularisation
d'un certain nombre d' affecte en
réalité qu'on a soi même et que l'on
cultive chez les autres c'est une façon
quand on a une façon de s'exprimer
notamment qu'on peut retrouver chez tram
et qui n'hésite pas à mettre à mal les
les conventions les c'est ça que vous
voulez jamais c'est pas simplement des
conventions c'est que la stylistique
général est une stylistique qui n'est
pas qu'au départ un principe quelconque
du bien commun etc
c'est une stylistique qui était au fond
une stylistique de de ce qu'on appelait
à un moment donné en france les les
conversations de bistrot c'est à dire
une manière d'aborder la politique dans
une thématique qui met au poste de
commandement au fond l'expression
affective qu'on peut avoir par rapport à
telle ou telle affirmation ou à tel ou
tel qui n'a pas peur de fâcher une
partie de la population et kid a et qui
est exactement qui d'accès qui acceptent
de diviser c'est qu'ils ne cherchent pas
comme beaucoup de politiciens classique
du parlementarisme une formule
partageable une formule modérés voire
même consensuel se sont pas des gens du
consensus sont pas descendus consommer
néanmoins même si j'exagère en disant
que vous les mettez dans le même cas
dans le
sac c'est quand même pas loin c'est à
dire que pour vous berlusconi ou nicolas
sarkozy prépare trempe un peu comme
comme dans l'irrésistible ascension
d'arthur oui la pièce de bertold brecht
les gangsters près par les nazis oui et
c'est là où j'ai l'impression que vous y
voyez un phénomène quand même le veut
ribeiro complet pour comprendre
complètement ce phénomène tu crois qu'il
faut faire une analyse plus large à ce
moment là qui est que je crois qu'il y a
actuel bord une crise mondiale de la
forme parlementaire de l'exercice de la
politique et que le surgissement de
personnages dans quelque sorte
extérieurs à la logique politique
ancienne est liée à cette crise et cette
crise je la crois lié au fait que ne
fonctionne plus véritablement ce que
j'appelle le consensus binaire c'est à
dire l'existence de deux organisations
politiques fortes
républicains et démocrates aux états
unis la gauche et à droite en france
les travaillistes et les conservateurs
en angleterre etc qui alternent au
pouvoir et qui peuvent alterner au
pouvoir parce que le consensus entre
elles il suffisant pour qu'elle le fasse
finalement et ça je pense que c'est en
train de dépérir
on a assisté aux états unis à des
divisions importantes chez les
démocrates qui sont en train de
s'aggraver et les républicains se sont
ralliés attrape un peu parce qu'ils
étaient contraints de le faire et si on
regarde les autres pays c'est la même
chose alors je pense que c'est ces
figures qui surgissent et que j'appelle
fascistes ou fascistoïde disons plutôt
fascistoïde sont et démocratique dans
lanaudière où elles elles surgissent du
processus électoral lui-même après train
pas été élu qu'on peut le discuter creux
mais il a été élu et on crie belgique 6
degrés des bêtes 800 directement et tous
les autres aussi ont aidé lui donc c'est
c'est démocratique en ce sens formel
mais en même temps ça exprime quelque
chose de la crise du sein parlementaire
lui-même et des catégories
traditionnelles qui quand même temps des
à dire qu'on rassemble les gens derrière
un groupe consistant d'idées qui
certainement sont compatibles en partie
avec les idées de l'adversaire mais qui
en même temps créer un écart est une
division qui permette l'alternance au
pouvoir
vous avez l'air de dire qu'en fait on
est passé d'affrontements ou des
oppositions binaires un dispositif à 4
terme
donc il y aura encore en france la
gauche et la droite mais où s'ajouterait
une extrême gauche et une extrême droite
aux états unis ça donne bernie sanders à
la fois qui est quand même plus à gauche
qu'on a presque jamais vue aux états
unis dans une primaire en tout cas qui
fait des voix les traits les plus à
droite voilà et des trams qui serait un
peu l'extrême droite oui oui après ça je
pense que la crise du binarisme
parlementaire classique gauche-droite
finalement sous toutes ses formes
engendre à l'heure actuelle dispositif
peut être transitoire de 2-2 2-4
polarité qui sont dans des tailleurs
dans des rapports de force extrêmement
variables mais on pourrait dire que le a
priori la démocratie parlementaire
représentatifs devrait pouvoir
s'accommoder de d'un dispositif à 4
terme c'est ne s'en est jamais
accommoder et facilement chaque fois
qu'un terme hétérogènes a surgi il a
fallu prendre des mesures d'exception
même en france le cas du parti
communiste a longtemps été un cas qui
mettait les équilibres parlementaire en
danger dans la mesure où tout le monde
s'engageait à ne pas travailler avec
l'ecc oblige jusqu'à l'épisode
mitterrand qui en fin de compte après
ces deux de très peu la mort dudit parti
donc la fré l'apparition du front
national qui avec un véhicule même
strass isme exactement mais le front
national pour l'instant plus beaucoup
plus récent que le parti communiste il
faut dire est encore bien en piste ce
que vous dites dans votre livre alain
badiou c'est que ces politiciens ces
voyous ce style voyou que vous leur
envoyez à chacun d'entre eux au fond ne
sont pas des politiciens classique
qu'ils ne sont d'ailleurs pas il ne
s'appuie pas sur la la bourgeoisie
cultivée
c'est ce qui explique aussi leur lors
leur franc parler ou en tout cas leur
vulgarité puisque vous parlez de
vulgarité dans votre livre
mais c'est quand même le ligue archi
pour vous c'est le ligueur chine
dominante france je pense qu'ils dans
que il entend contradiction a eu
beaucoup de mode mais sur le fond et
n'entre pas en contradiction avec
l'oligarchie
mais nantes et ça quelle que soit la
variante de ses personnages
si on prend bol de naro au brésil il est
tout à fait quasiment un mandataire
reconnu de l'oligarchie dominante au
brésil si on prend du tertre aux
philippines c'est pareil d'une certaine
manière très possible
ça veut pas dire que tout le monde aime
que tout le monde est pour lui que tout
le monde souhaite qu'ils restent là dans
l'oligarchie ça veut dire qu'il fait
avec qui traite avec et que l'ensemble
de sa politique est cohérente finalement
avec ce que désire l'oligarchie c'est à
dire des modes d'application d'ailleurs
variable de l'économie d'un pays
avec la mondialisation du capital parce
que la crise je voudrais revenir là
dessus
sais tu cries de la politique en général
et cette crise à la raison suivante à
mon sens c'est que au fond de plus en
plus l'économie dans son nom dans la
circulation générale est réellement
mondialisé le moindre objet que d'eau
que nous pratiquons a souvent comme
provenance sept ou huit origines
nationales et locales tout à fait
différencier l'analyse a été faite pour
les téléphones portables téléphones
portables sont 1 1 a concentré
d'internationalisme marange depuis dix
ans et donc économique comme ça mais le
pouvoir politique ne l'ait pas encore du
tout il ya les tentatives de diriger
réellement des des autorités mondiales
sont très limitées et très impuissante
et donc le poids politique reste
nationale
je pense qu'à partir du moment où se
pose la question de comment on intègre
finalement ce poids politique nationale
dans une économie mondialisée surgissent
d'un très important de contradictions
qui vont finalement opposé aux deux
extrêmes une tendance de repli
nationaliste à laquelle participe en
partie mais ils virent il va tenir
exactement mêlant participantes ans qui
se veut aussi le pays dominants de tout
le système donc c'est et il en a les
moyens ce qui est particulier et puis à
l'autre extrémité des tentatives de dire
il faut s'en prendre la mondialisation
capitaliste elle même il faut il faudra
au coeur
les tentatives gauchistes néo
communistes etc
et entre ces deux là tentent de survivre
aux faux les partis traditionnels et je
pense que c'est ça le paysage général et
comment va-t-on surmonter cette
contradiction finalement entre le
caractère mondialisé de la circulation
économique est le caractère localisée du
pouvoir politique
c'est un problème que non je vois pas
très bien que l'on être les issues
effectivement la démocratie et locales
alors que le capitalisme lui et mondiale
le marché donc écho mais qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une démocratie de marché
alors on y reviendra peut-être mais très
peu et la milliardaire qui a réussi
quand même à se faire élire avec les
voix du des classes laborieuses des
vraiment des classes arabe et c'est
aussi un type sexistes c'est vous qui le
décrivait comme un type sexisme vous
n'êtes pas le seul
je sais si l' on lui a reproché à sa
tombe re d'horreur concernant ses
rapports avec avec les femmes est
néanmoins les femmes ont voté pour lui
comment vous expliquez cela alain badiou
et il ya si peu de conscience de classe
mais la conscience de classe la
conscience de classe est un concept et
qu'il faut examiner de près même marque
reconnaît qu' il existe dans les classes
pauvres et même dans les plus pauvres
qu'ils appellent le lumpen prolétariat
d'aisance politique tout à fait
étrangère au communisme qu'il propose
est de toute évidence si la démocratie
au sens électorale a été possible dans
la maintenance indéfinie du système
capitaliste y compris sous ses formes
paroxystique
c'est bien qu'il ya des appuis
populaires pour des politiques qui sont
anti populaires rappelons que que et
mussolini et hitler ont joué leur parti
aussi dans le cadre parlementaire
et quand ils ont obtenu de majorité ils
ont été majoritaires on peut pas le
être un beau si une majorité il ya tout
ce dont nous parlons boyzone à otc sont
des gens qui ont été élus donc le le
fait d'être en définitive le
représentant voir le garant politique
provisoire de la mondialisation
capitaliste dans son ensemble n'est pas
du tout exclusif de la possibilité
d'obtenir un appui populaire parce que
l'appui populaire peut s'organiser dans
des idéologies très différentes
elle n'est pas à elle la conviction
politico idéologique n'est pas des
débats n'est pas du tout n'est pas du
tout mécanique
en particulier elle suppose un travail
compliqué et difficile de deux polarités
intellectuelle et politique organisée or
c'est celle là qui ont dépéri aux rites
et je pense que la grande
le grand problème aujourd'hui c'est le
problème de qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
organisation politique qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une organisons politique qui
serait à la fois hétérogènes au système
dans son ensemble est capable de se
développer en même temps dans l'élément
de ce système
c'est une question qui est pendante
depuis en réalité l'échec des pays
communistes et attiser la chine où là où
la russie échec qui sont d'ailleurs
différents l'un de l'autre mais qui sont
deux échecs et cette question a faibli
de façon considérable ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le pôle gauche du
parlementarisme et encore plus son pôle
d'extrême gauche potentiel est-ce que
donald trump ne referme pas à sa manière
la parenthèse ouverte on va dire par
margaret thatcher et et et ronald reagan
en 1979-80 ce qu'on a appelé depuis le
néolibéralisme est ce que trempe avec un
certain nombre de mesures
protectionnistes avec cette volonté
qu'il a de protéger le marché américain
de la concurrence à savoir chinoises et
européennes d'ailleurs parce que nous
sommes dedans
est ce que au fond il ne cherche pas à
protéger aussi son peuple contrôlée et
contre cette concurrence qui le
tamoil il ya une chose est à vie les
états unis n'ont plus la puissance
économique qu'ils avaient autrefois
oui mais je pense que là aussi nous
avons une conclusion ambigu parce que la
position de deux trains ce n'est pas du
tout la même position que celle des
autres entités nationales dans le monde
sauf peut être en effet la chanson
chinoise
sa position est aussi de défendre un
principe hégémonique américain il veut à
la fois ne pas supporter la concurrence
mais lui il veut imposer son diktat
on le voit par les interventions
constantes qu'il fait en direction de la
corée du nord dans l'hostilité à la
chine par les interventions très
compliqué d'ailleurs au moyen-orient par
ce qui vient de se produire du soutien
total à israël une double gestion chez
trimpe il ya la gestion en effet la
tentation de fond d'une figure nationale
repliée sur elle-même barricadé quant à
sa production etc
mais il ya aussi le fait de défendre ce
qui est la véritable force des états
unis c'est à dire un son absolu
souveraineté militaire
on sait que l'équipement militaire des
états unis pratiquement équivalent de
l'équipement militaire de tout le reste
du monde avec une confrérie
contradictions chinoise qui est en train
de monter sur ce point et d'autre part
de maintenir ce qui est vraiment
l'alimentation même de l'hégémonie
américaine c'est la souveraineté du
dollar s'est fait que le dollar demeure
une monnaie de change mondialisée
quand il brandit des sanctions contre
les sociétés où les états qui
continueraient à négocier avec l'iran
il le fait sous la menace que on le
retire at toutes leurs possibilités de
manoeuvrer en dollars les
investissements en dollars et c est que
ça demeure malgré tout un impératif
absolu
comment la scène de vous et aidez
d'ailleurs dans votre livre vous dites
comment se fait-il que les non seulement
alors il sera tire une élite
unilatéralement de désaccords sur le
nucléaire iranien mais en plus les
autres sont obligés de le suivre et vous
étonnez que les grandes entreprises
françaises
se coucher elle aussi devant le diktat
de canal est ce qui coûte la cause de la
souveraineté mondialisée du championnat
fermée mais parce qu'elles n'ont pas
elles ne peuvent pas faire autrement
sinon elles ne peuvent pas faire
autrement mais si elle était soutenue
par un accord effectif de l'ensemble des
puissances occidentales
elle pourrait en fin de compte faire
autrement d'ailleurs et puis sortir d'un
talent ont prétendu faire un certain
nombre d'efforts pour tenter de voir si
on pouvait pas faire un secteur de
financement alternatif aux
investissements étrangers en dollars ça
n'a pas été fait sérieusement et
personne n'y a cru vraiment donc ça a
montré sa un simple rapport de force
entre les puissances occidentales apn et
et et les amis ça et je remonte pas de
là votre question c'est à dire que trump
s'est ces deux choses connect mais qui
n'ont pas complètement identique en
effet un certain nationale au populisme
américain d'un côté avec des
caractéristiques fascistoïde flagrante
dans la manière de parler dans le mépris
etc
mais c'est aussi la défense et ça ça a
été une continuité américaine de
l'hégémonie américaine dans le monde qui
en effet est par ailleurs relativement
menacée mais dont on voit dans
l'exercice des choses qu'elle demeure
quand même très étendu et très efficace
tendu est ce qu'il n'ya pas chez 30
profond une manifestation là encore moi
j'y vois beaucoup d'états lèche de la
force mais n'est pas un étalage de la
force assumer c'est à dire qu'on prend
pas de gants on y va car je suis le plus
fort et puis je suis allé au fond il a
il n'a pas les manières qu'on pouvait
avoir autrefois mais l'état lâche de la
force est elle-même mais mais c'était
plus étaient plus nuancées c'était plus
élégant on va dire peu de riz et puis de
la part de toutes les grandes puissances
aussi bien l'union soviétique
unis ce que la france l'angleterre c'est
donc c'est tout à fait vrai mais ça
dépend à quelle échelle temporelle vous
vous situez parce que l'état l'âge de la
force pendant quand même l'essentiel du
temps d'existence des sociétés
occidentales et capitaliste c'est quand
même soldés par des guerres meurtrières
de façon effrayante des guerres ou
l'échelle du nombre des morts où la
blessure de la pop et des populations
étaient considérables et tout laisse à
penser que si cette logique était
reconstituée aujourd'hui ça serait
encore bien pire
un son comme véore à vrai dire personne
ne sait ce que pourrait être une guerre
mondiale dans les conditions du présent
vu les armements disponibles et ce qui
s'est produit en 14 puis en 40 a été à
chaque fois le spectacle de massac
encore plus considérable que la dernière
fois et donc je pense que c est ce que
ce que ce que vous dites concerne les
tâches de la force est vrai oui il
s'agit d'une politique d'état l'âge de
la force que le plus fort et talent plus
que les autres savent à l'arrêt
l'angleterre et la france le faisait
aussi vous avez à l'arrière-plan ce
n'est pas sans raison qu'on à mios sur
pied péniblement des politique de
confrontation modérée entre nations
parce que malgré tout personne ne sait
ce que peut donner la guerre et les
leçons des deux précédentes reste quand
même extrêmement extrêmement pesant
c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé la
diplomatie et ça fonctionne la
diplomatie entre le conflit armé on
dirait que très peu rompent avec les
règles de la d'immeubles qui consiste
essentiellement à être diplomate
il n'est pas diplomate et est exactement
mais je pense que c'est une
caractéristique de de ski fascistoïde de
ne pas aimer la diplomatie et c'était
avec pio je veux dire les si on voit
comment se c'est qu'on sort s'est
comporté hitler dans à partir des années
30 on voit que l'action n'était jamais
diplomatiquement constitué mais elle
était constituée autrement et trump
c'est un peu la même chose alors à
mettre tout et tout et tout et tout est
relatif
mais sur les catégories justement du
rapport entre force et paix entre
diplomatie et a cherché en guerrière et
montrer ses muscles
il ya une logique nouvelle dans le ce
personnage on fait une pause label bio
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de kiel de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fonio et sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
passe
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation le citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les appuis
[Musique]
nous sommes ce soir avec un badiou le
philosophe alain badiou qui publie trump
aux éditions du presses universitaires
de france un livre dans lequel vous
parlez beaucoup du capitalisme ce
capitalisme mondialisé aujourd'hui alain
badiou le capitalisme vous dites c'est
devenu l' idéologie commune au fond un
plus personne ne leur met réellement
question normal c'est sans enthousiasme
qu'on y adhère
on n'y serait plus ou moins contraint ce
serait un consensus négatif dites vous
oui je crois je crois que je crois que
je crois qu'en réalité pendant toute une
période
le capitalisme a dû argumenter et tenter
de mettre en avant les arguments en sa
faveur contre un adversaire quand qui
s'identifiaient dans la version
socialiste dans l'aviation communis a
dépendu des périodes
enfin un adversaire constitué
définissant une autre stratégie générale
pour le devenir de l'humanité
je pense que ceci dans les années 80 à
peu près disparu je pense qu'au peuple
press ap c'est la date à peu près
charnière ce qui a disparu c'est l'idée
d'une alternative
ça a permis de constituer un autre
système propagandistes général
concernant le capitalisme c'était que
n'était peut-être pas absolument fameux
dans tout les domaines mais que c'était
la seule voie praticable seule voie
raisonnable
la seule voie de développement effectif
de l'humanité dans le monde contemporain
et donc nous nous ne nous nous sommes
dans un dans un monde dans lequel d'une
certaine façon il ya au sens strict
une idéologie dominante qui a des tas de
ramifications et de diversité mais qui
sur le fond considère que la l'existence
d'une appropriation privée des grands
moyens de
production est inéluctable et nécessaire
ou là et je pense que ça c'est quand
même une grande différence avec ce qui
s'est produit et en matière politique
depuis dix ans le milieu du 19e siècle
mais à vos yeux le capitalisme n'a
vraiment rien pour lui
bien sûr que si la dame pour lui il
reconnaissait et là bas il a des choses
pour lui s'il avait pas des choses pour
lui n'aurait pas pu et n'aurait pas pu
tout simplement vaincre son adversaire
avait justement pour vaincre son
adversaire
il avait notamment il avait notamment
pour lui
d'une part une efficacité productive
indubitable centrer sans précédent
historique et que d'une certaine manière
le lait le communisme établis dans des
pays largement à rire et sur ce plan n'a
et n'a plus que courir après ce qui est
donc il avait cette supériorité là il
avait la supériorité de y compris d'un
développement militaire et territoriales
établie de longue date et il avait aussi
la supériorité d'avoir inventé et
produit le système politique dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure le système
politique démocratique aux
parlementaires qui instaure la
conviction qu en outre il y a quand même
une certaine marque de choix dans les
orientations y compris le sens de
l'intérêt général dudit capital
constitue un ensemble un ensemble que
d'ailleurs on appelle la démocratie
parce que elle elle est la propagande
occidentale ne se fait jamais au nom du
capitalisme se fait toujours au nom de
la démocratie démocratie et le non
civilisés et protecteur du capitalisme y
compris quand ce qu'a vu la leaf ne
devient très concentré très féroce donc
cet ensemble constitué des avantages
importants bien évidemment est-ce que
vous ne voyez pas le capitalisme depuis
sa naissance à la fin du moyen-age à nos
rêves en italie et dans les flandres
comme une force terriblement
révolutionnaire au fond c'est fou ce que
le capitalisme a changé il s'est dressé
il a été le premier pratiquement la
première organisation à se dresser
contre l'arbitraire des princes et
contre le fanatisme des prêtres c'est à
partir du droit de la propriété que cet
établissement est constituée l'état de
droit
sans les échanges marchands on n'aurait
jamais codifié tout ça en tout cas pas
de la même manière sans doute pas mais
bien sûr il était révolutionnaire le
cabinet et peut-être les t-il encore
d'ailleurs les tenants du capitaliste du
capitalisme se flatte d'avoir sorti plus
de 800 millions de personnes de
l'extrême pauvreté de mai j'ai compté
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
exact actuellement c'est tout à fait
exact et je pense que de ce point de vue
là dans un ensemble que je considère
qu'il faut construire comme façon
beaucoup plus vaste et c'est à dire
l'histoire néolithique de l'humanité
c'est-à-dire celle qui s'est constitué
il ya quatre ou cinq mille ans autour
d'eux justement à la propriété privée
l'agriculture sédentaires aux mamans les
chasseurs cueilleurs nos ancêtres c'est
la saison sarila sein du chasseur
cueilleur et et et avec tout ça l'état
destinée à protéger justement
l'organisation de la société
on est entré dans une nouvelle période
de l'histoire d'humanité et il est hors
de doute que le capitalisme est le
couronnement l'achèvement probable de de
cet immense séquence ce qui donne aussi
une certaine amplitude à toute idée de
d'aller au-delà toute idée d'aller au
delà c'est quand même comme si on
proposait une sortie de cet édifice
néolithique qui quand même nous ad
animalisés qui fut dire café de
l'humanité l'appareil peut être
monstrueux qu'elle est sur cette planète
donc voila et capitalisme ça désigne ça
ça désigne la figure en effet à la fois
paroxystique à mon avis terminal d'une
séquence historique de plusieurs
millénaires
alors on peut toujours dire évidemment
que l état bien des égards supérieure à
tout ce qui a précédé
ça c'est indubitable et certains disent
qu au fond le communisme pourrait très
bien d'être venir il faudrait que le
capitalisme souhaite aller au bout
d'abord c'est à dire qu' il faudrait que
ce le communisme peut s'installer dans
l'abondance qu'il ne peut pas le faire
dans la pénurie
qu'en pensez vous
défenseurs de l'hypothèse communiste
mais je pense qu'il ya je pense qu'il ya
une vérité là dedans mais elles m'ont
ont un de mes maîtres en communisme qui
a été fait et elle tu sers le philosophe
althusser disait souvent qu'il fallait
pas il fallait pas oublier que la partie
fondamentale ne se jouer certainement
pas à cuba ou peut-être même pas en
chine et peut même pas en russie
finalement mais dans les grandes
métropoles qui sont les piliers du
capitalisme lui-même que c'était là que
ça devait se passer je serai c'est
d'accord je serais assez d'accord le
destin de l'humanité toute entière ne se
décidera pas sa périphérie
la moins avancée dans les constructions
néolithique donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
nous inventions que nous tentions de
créer un nouveau communiqué le garde le
mot parce que parce que j'en ai pas
trouvé d'autres hameaux du jeu avec abu
appropriée est capable de s'enraciner y
compris dans les métropoles l'impérial
résultats de de plusieurs siècles de
construction la crise de la démocratie
représentative qui est pour vous un des
fondements s'il ya ce type de d'hommes
politiques qui arrivent au pouvoir
aujourd'hui
dites-vous je parle de 30 mais aussi
bolt sonar ou de houe de berlusconi
c'est parce qu'il ya une crise de la
démocratie représentative vous le disais
tout à l'heure parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
aurait éventuellement quatre ce serait
des dispositifs 1,4 terme et plus est
deux termes
mais ce n est pas suffisant il ya
forcément quelque chose d'autre est ce
que le fait que le le capitalisme s'est
mondialisée pour vous participe de cette
crise de la démocratie représentative
sans aucun doute puisque la démocratie
représentative pour l'instant restent
pour l'essentiel nationale elle n'a pas
elle n'est pas arrivée elle ne sait pas
comment arriver à une disposition qui
excéderait cette limite
les européens ont fait des efforts
continus est considérable pour que ça
aille un peu dans cette direction mais
on voit aujourd'hui que ces efforts sont
très limités qui sont même entrés en
crise là
tente depuis pas mal d'années et donc je
pense que le système politique qui
serait capable de constituer une sorte
d'opposition novatrices à échelle du
monde
c'est une figure que deux qui n'est pas
vraiment présente à l'esprit c'était une
figure pourtant proposé dès le début
parce que marx n'a jamais imaginé que
l'organisation politique communiste
pouvait être nationale il a touché tout
de suite dit c'est une internationale et
c'était à nationale ont été se trouvait
largement nationalisées dent dans l'oeil
dans l'histoire quand on a vu que c'est
ta national devenait abandonné un
instrument de l'action internationale de
l'union soviétique mais bon donc là
aussi de voir un rapport entre nationale
et internationale qui met en crise une
partie de la démocratie parlementaire et
qui crée par ailleurs un obstacle
considérable pour un internationalisme
nouveau et comment on est au fond assez
d'une opposition classique à une
opposition plus compliqué d'où ce qui
permet de voir émerger des personnalités
assez étonnante y compris comme bernie
sanders
comment expliquez-vous le phénomène
bernie sanders aux états unis face à 30
qui normalement vite ya une tension
beaucoup plus intéressante entre trempe
et bernie sanders contre trempe et
hillary clinton ou entre la dizaine
d'heures et hillary clinton
bien entendu et je pense que le ce
déplacement des centres de gravité comme
ça dans l' équilibre des tendances au
sein de la démocratie parlementaire est
un fait nouveau
quant à elle expliqué je pense que c'est
tout simplement que
l' équilibre ancien de type disons
social-démocrate quoi là le centre de
gravité de go c'était ça c'était la
démocratie c'est à dire on n'a pas de
propos révolutionnaires véritablement
mais il faut veiller quand même à ce que
les bénéfices du capitalisme ne soit un
petit peu répartie soi même bien
redistribuer le redis c'est heureux
distribué convenablement cette
opposition de fond ne fonctionne plus et
donc c'est sur le terrain de ce
dysfonctionnement que surgissent des
hypothèses plus radicale des deux côtés
du côté gauche
aux etats unis un bernie sanders qui
quand même en effet est porteur de
propositions inédites dans le contexte
américain et de l'autre côté
trump qui est aussi un espèce de
raidissement à la fois nationale et
impérial de type nouveau
alors je pense que c'est ça et là dedans
c'est dans l'élément de cette crise que
je pense que peut et doit surgir une
opposition plus plus globale c'est à
dire plus qui serait stratégiquement
extérieures au système lui-même et qui
se propose réelles de clore en réalité
la séquence capitalisme du néolithique
entier donc c'est une affaire haïtienne
la première fois on l'a vu c'était en
octobre 1917 pour la première fois on a
remis en question la propriété privée
personne ne l'avait jamais fait jusque
là oui oui personne ne l'avait jamais
fait et de fait en réalité on savait pas
ce que ça voulait dire parce que ça a
été fait mais ça a été fait dans une
obscurité brutale qui montre à quel
point une première expérience de ce
genre est une expérience en rite est
précaire il voudrait rappeler que dès la
fin des années 20 lénine lui même
considère que la chose a échoué dès la
fin des années 20 les 10 10 mais
finalement notre état tel qu'il est là
il n' a rien de vraiment meilleur que
que l'état cela risque précédent il est
d'une très violent cela qu il avait vu
que l'état allait être henry tello
boulet de la nouvelle organisation et je
pense que il ne faut pas s'étonner que
les expérimentations dans cette
direction était finalement à la fois si
violente est si précaire
il ya quelque chose qui nous manque
encore il nous manque au fond
d'acclimater l'idée générale d'une
économie collectiviser à la réalité du
capitalisme contemporain alors en italie
revenant à l'italie puisque les tapis
qui fait toujours des expériences
originales on a vu après berlusconi on a
vu apparaître le mouvement 5 étoiles et
et qu'il arrive au pouvoir en s'alliant
avec avec la ligue la ligue 2 puis à
quitter le pouvoir mais il ya eu cette
alliance pour vous vous lavez analyser
comment cette surgissement je pense que
je pense que nous avons beaucoup de
surgissement de cet ordre dans le monde
contemporain il faut pas oublier que le
monde compte après est un monde agité un
de là nous parlons des structures les
structures sont toujours là et c'est
enfin si on additionne l'apparition du
mouvement 5 étoiles en italie est
aujourd'hui l'apparition du mouvement
dit les sardines est encore une
expérimentation nouvelles par rapport
aux 5 étoiles
si on considère les gigantesques colère
de masse que l'on trouve dans tous les
pays a pratiquement en algérie au liban
en irak la situation catastrophique en
syrie si on ajoute le fait que dans de
nombreux pays même occidentaux comme
l'anneau comme le d'autres il ya tout de
même des mobilisations populaires
durable importante confuse mais
existante si on prend tout ce panorama
en on a on a le sentiment que henry t je
dirais la politique elle-même et ancré
la petite parlementaire est en crise on
peut si on peut examiner pourquoi je
pense que c'est l'idée politique est
elle même en crise parce que d'une
certaine façon le capitalisme a nous a
habitués à ce que l'appareil politique
soit grosso modo à son service tout en
essayant de le faire travailler quand
même pour un plus grand nombre que ses
bénéficiaires immédiats
je pense que je pense que ça c'est cet
accord qui a été en fait recéler après
les deux guerres mondiales telles que si
elle pas eu la guerre mondiale on aurait
continué sur une toute autre voie cet
accord
était scellé après les guerres mondiales
il est remis en question de façon
systématique
aujourd'hui le petit de macron ça n'est
quand même rien d'autre que de défaire
systématiquement tout ce qui était mis
en place dans les années 50 et 60
et du coup la question de savoir qu'est
ce qui va advenir du point de vue du
surgissement possible d'un nouveau d'une
nouvelle vision de la politique est tout
à fait obscur et donc je serais partisan
de la thèse qu'aujourd'hui la politique
pratiquement yade a pas y en a pas si si
on entend par politique comme ça se fait
quand même depuis plateau la présence
dans le mouvement populaire et dans les
actions des intellectuels etc d'un
certain nombre de principes qui compte
qu'ils sont capables en état de
rassembler des totalités humaine alors
il ya eu le surgissement en france des
gilets jaunes qui était un mouvement qui
a beaucoup occupé des ronds-points
d'abord mais aussi de centre d'un
certain nombre de grandes villes
et cela pendant un laps de temps quand
même considérable qui a gagné d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière dans son rapport
de force avec le pouvoir ils ont obtenu
ce qu'ils demandaient et puis ensuite le
mouvement a continué a eu moins de
soutien de la population mais quand même
ce soutien était très important pendant
un certain temps plus de deux tiers des
français soutenaient ce mouvement vous
l'avez vous soutenu alain badiou jeux
les jeux les jeunes et je n'ai pas
soutenu vraiment je n'ai pas soutenu
vraiment parce que le système
programmatique et organisé de ce
mouvement des villes et jaune me
paraissait resté tout à fait internes au
système existant
il a commencé par une classique révolte
anti taxe qui me rappelait quand même le
poujadisme des années 50-60 que tout le
monde a oublié
moi je n'ai pas oublié il a continué de
façon très anarchisante en réalité est
très peu organisés très peu
programmatique
on dit qu'il a gagné mais qu'est ce
qu'il a gagné au fond je ne saurais pas
le dire la taxe a été abandonnée une
chose c'est que quelques milliards ont
été distribués oui voilà quelques
milliards ont été distribués pas
forcément
ailleurs mais aux rousses mika enfin
population délaissée
et puis il ya eu un recul sur les impôts
mais ce recul est très très très très
ciblée très très très limité donc parler
d'une victoire d'exécution de cet excès
cif au regard de ce qu'a été le
mouvement ce sont des bricoles
véritablement et ça c'est le premier
point est le premier pas je n'ai rien vu
chez lui qui soient des propositions en
entités bâti crise veut dire c'étaient
des propositions radicales au sens le
plus minimal du terme c'était des
propositions qui ne faisait que dire
nous acceptons tout à fait tout ce qu'il
y a mais macron nous entend pas voilà et
alors ça c'est un point que je considère
aussi comme très important je pense que
dès qu'un mouvement est ciblée sur une
personne dans les conditions générales
du capitaine globalisé c'est un
mouvement affaibli par ce point même
parce qu'en fin de compte macron sait
pas grand chose du foner mam macron
c'est une pièce du système est un peu
une pièce rapportée d'ailleurs c'est le
résultat de la crise de la gauche et de
la droite il a fallu sortir un phénomène
nouveau
c'est ce qui s'était passé au siècle
dernier avec napoléon iii bac rond c'est
un impôt leurs trois civils en fait
quelque chose comme ça avec quand même
vu mais à peu près du même âge
d'ailleurs oui à peu près du même âge
avec peut-être moins d'invention devant
lui parce que napoléon iii quand même
celui qui a copié l'angleterre et donner
un coup d'accélérateur au développement
du capitalisme français il faut lui la
révolution industrielle en vertu macro
il est quand même dans une pollution
beaucoup plus défensivement fin ils
essaient de privatiser tout ce qui peut
être fait est fait qu'il fait quand même
un peu cette politique là et le leu leu
macron dégage toute cette politique
dégage east qui a été inaugurée déjà
dans l'est dans les pays arabes
au moment des printemps arabes moubarak
dégage est là moubarak a dégagé baisse
qui est venu après c'est pire et bacrot
pourrait dégager condé pire ça c'est pas
du tout exclu
et j'ai l'impression que votre livre sur
30/0 pu l'intituler de quoi trump est il
le nom dieu sait si ce titre que je vais
redonner à votre livre sur sarkozy et
vous a été pillée de toutes les sauces
est-ce que ça n'était pas au fond vous
vous est-ce que vous ne vous êtes pas
posé la même question de quoi trempe est
il le nom sarkozy vous aimeriez que
c'était le long de la peur oui il y
avait une couleur et il fallait que
sarkozy sarkozy l heure était arrivée au
pouvoir
parce que l sa tombe deux français
avaient peur tram ce serait quoi
ben je pense que je voudrais dire
d'abord que les conditions dans
lesquelles j'ai n'ont pas écrit ce livre
mais parler ce livre mais ce sont des
différents staffs aux états unis sont
tout à fait particulière parce que
c'était une des conférences données aux
états unis et dont l'une était le jour
même vers les fixes à des élections et
donc j'avais enfin deux mois des
étudiants des enseignants de
l'université de californie qui était
dans un état de 2 2 défaites et 2 de
préoccupation extrême
en plus il avait cru jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin que c'était que c'était hillary
clinton qui était élu et donc ça leur
est tombée dessus vraiment comme une
comme une catastrophe presque
imprévisible presque inouïe et donc je
me suis dis je qu'est ce que je peux
quelle est ma fonction dans cette
affaire et je me suis dit ma fonction
ces deux-là expliqué que être tristes
abattus etc
je les comprends très bien mais ça ne
servira à rien dans la conjoncture et
par conséquent je je leur ai dit il faut
chercher alors j'aurais dit là plutôt de
comprendre est le symptôme que nous
voilà de quoi être un peu le symptôme
sur quelle arrière plan y at-il une
possibilité de train comme je dirais
aujourd'hui finalement sur quel
arrière-plan mondialisée y at il une
multiplication de ces figures légèrement
monstrueuse hétérogènes au capitalisme
sous sa forme parlementaire normale
voilà et alors c'est pour ça que ça a
pris ce tour ça a pris ce tour de dire
en effet un petit peu de quoi être un
petit le symbole et trump et airbus yeux
le symbole de tout ce dont nous venons
de discuter c'est à dire quelque chose
comme quand même un dérèglement
politique universelle mais on peut dire
que train
le ca bonne aussi d'une certaine
droitisation du monde dieu sait si on
l'a théorisé la droitisation du monde
depuis le début des années 80 est-ce que
vous n'observez pas au même moment une
gauchisation du monde c'est à dire que
je pense que je pense qu' il faudrait
sans doute sortir des catégories droite
et gauche parce que ce sont les
catégories parlementaire elle même
donc si on dit qu'il faut gauchir le
monde on est en train de dire qu' il
faut d'une certaine manière revenir au
bon vieux temps où au fond les
espérances pouvait se cristalliser sur
des organisations de gauche dont on
attendait qu'elle améliore le système
talent je suis pas sûr qu'on va revenir
à sa aisée morin
je pense que c'est peut-être le temps
perdu mais est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
penser que les thèmes on va dire qu'on
pourrait qualifier de gauche pour
simplifier sont en train de reprendre du
poil de la bête les inégalités la lutte
contre les inégalités on n'en parlait
pas dans les années 80 donnerait peut
dans les années 90 on en parle de plus
en plus quand bien même ces inégalités
d'ailleurs serait pas forcément en train
de s'élargir de grossir autant qu'on le
pense mais peu importe les inégalités
c'est souvent du ressenti plus que plus
que des statistiques oui mais on voit
bien que ça cesse est en train de monter
monter monter
oui oui ça c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
d'un certain point de vue c c'est encore
dans un état pré politique terre il ya
des grands mouvements aujourd'hui je les
salue tous d'une manière ou d'une autre
il y a il ya des grands mouvements c'est
aussi des occasions de transformation
subjective
c'est l'occasion d'apparition de
nouveaux groupes et de nouvelles forces
donc je suis
je suis content qu'il y ait ces
mouvements y compris ici naturellement
vers l'autre côté et il faut plus que
des bouffes bord à fond les
transformations politiques profondes
que ce soit la révolution française où
la révolution de 1917 ou tout autre
transformation qui ne mériterait pas
forcément le nom de révolution
elles se font toujours pas une espèce de
de fusion entre une idée nouvelle
partageable est en effet un mouvement
revendicatif vigoureux je vois bien le
mouvement revendicatif vigoureux mais je
vois pas les départager a même l'idée de
la lutte contre les inégalités c'est
unis
négative encore ça n'est pas ce n'est
pas dire ce qu'on veut c'est de dire ce
qu'on ne veut pas alors si peu de points
ça la politique commence quand on sait
ce qu'on veut et non pas seulement ce
qu'on ne veut pas vous venez de citer la
révolution française et la révolution
russe dans les deux cas au fond le
pouvoir qu est l a pourtant depuis très
très longtemps tombe sans qu'on ait même
besoin de le pousser
c'était c'est fascinant après ça va
devenir dur après il va y avoir la
guerre après il va y avoir les les
coalitions internationales aussi bien
contre la révolution française que
contre la révolution mais au départ il
n'y a même pas besoin de verser le sang
au fond oui c'est pour ça que le don
révolution doit être examinée de près
d'ailleurs si la révolution est un
projet longuement mûri qui à jour donne
une mutation radicale
c'est un concept tout à fait abstrait
d'ailleurs il est il est resté abstrait
longtemps dans les internationale entre
les deux guerres
parce qu'il n'a pas vu le fait très
important que que vous soulignez mais
justement dans un cas on sait
parfaitement de quoi ici c'est la guerre
la guerre de 14 et la guerre mondiale
qui avait défait en réalité le pouvoir
est athée que russes et dans l'autre cas
on connaît en tout cas la longue
préparation idéologique qui était la
philosophie des lumières et ses
partisans qui a réanimé
l'idée démocratique en même temps que
cette idée trouver une première
incarnation dans la révolution anglaise
dont il faut jamais sous-estimer quand
même l'important c'est la révolution
américaine exactement américaine
complément de la révolution anglaise
donc je vous avez raison mais justement
le la question aujourd'hui est
transformé d'abord par l'amplitude du
défi si j'ai raison de dire que le
communisme nouveau doit assumer qu'il
est la sortie des des politiques donc la
fin de quatre mille ans d'histoire est
pas la fin de maquereaux voilà et
deuxièmement par le fait que les les
considérations de la politique
aujourd'hui sont obscures
alors que dans les deux révolutions que
nous citons elle ne l'était pas le
pouvoir adverse était identifiable
aujourd'hui quand on dit dégage bacrot
on ne cible pas le pouvoir en tant que
tel ça n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas une
figure du pouvoir qu'on voudrait
détruire c'est une personne et tram
c'est la même chose et j'aiderai y est
ça c'est la rançon du fait qu'ils ont
été élus donc aidera donc d'une manière
ou d'une autre il faudra engager aussi
une méditation profonde sur cette
question de la démocratie électorale
merci l âme à dieu d'avoir pas de si
belles cette émission je rappelle que
votre livre s'intitule trump et qu'il
est sorti aux presses universitaires de
france merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]